- Ce qu'on vise là, c'est
de recruter 10 000 personnes.
- Le 27 mai 2020, alors que
de partout, François Legault
annonce la formation accélérée
de 10 000 préposés
aux bénéficiaires.
La veille, les consultantse e ey
recommandaient justement
d'acrererer la formation
et les embauches en CHSLD.
Malgré tout, François Legaut
cécécécécécécécécécécécécécécécs
aux bénéficiaires,c'c'c'était b.
- Totalement! Totalement.
Puis j'en suis fier.
- Radio-Canada a mis la main
entre la firme privée et
la haute fonction publique.
McKinsey conseillait
notamment le directeur de
la campagne de vaccination.
Daniel Paré reçoit un courriel
d'un a l l l l l l l l l l l l :
Le 29 avril 2020,
mimiministratrice d'État
Le 29 avril 2020,tttttttttttttt
au ministère de la Santé,
Dominique Savoieclclclame
l'aide de la firme externe
pour prendre une décision
cruciale afin, écrlllllle :dedex
prochaines années dans
nos achats et stocks pour
nos équipements prioritaires
(masques et blouses)."
Le recours à McKinsey
était justifié,
le chef de la CAQ.
FRANCitititititititititititititc
- En bout de ligne, c'était moi
puononon équipe qui prenaient
les décisions. Mais je pense
que les recommandations
de McKinsey, nous ont aidés
à sauver deeseses.
- Mais ce n'est pas
l'avis de ses adversaires.
parole, Québec solidaire
- Pendant qu'il y avait
du monde sur le terrain
qui demandait à être écouté,
François Legault a préféré
d'une firme multinationale.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe, PLQ
- Il aime gouverner seul,
il aime gouvernenr
sans qu'on le critique,
partager l'information.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, cheCQCQCQ
- McKinsey semble avoir joué
un rôle très important dans
la gestion de MOMOMOMOMOMOMOMOM,
chef, Parti québécois
- François Lltltlt
nous présentait ça comme
les décisions du gouvernement,
alors qutrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrts
entre ce que dit McKinsey c c ct
le jour même ou le surlendemaine
de critiques, François Legault
explique que c'est la fonction
McKinsey. Un contrat de plus
de 6 millions de dollars
accordé sans appel d'offres.
Ici Pascal Poinlane,
Radio-Canada, à Québe